there's a guy named elon musk
who might be a candidate for
such an unraveling
right you mentioned uh
the person that speaks up could be a
donald trump but in this current uh
situation we live in like as this week
uh elon has purchased twitter that's
what i hear
and it's pushing for
um in all kinds of ways the increase of
free speech on twitter
and speaking about some of the
issues that we've been speaking about
here
with you but maybe in broader strokes
about just
the fact that you have to
it's okay to point out that the emperor
wears no clothes and to do so
from all sides in a way that everybody's
a little bit pissed off but not too much
what do you think about this whole
effort of free speech
uh on in these public platforms um elon
in particular twitter your uh avid
twitter user
um but just public platforms for
discourse for us as a civilization to
figure stuff out yeah well
the people on the left are very upset
about the possibility that elon musk
and twitter will be open to more open to
uh provocative uh public speech that has
heretofore been banned or suppressed
and
i think they might be right to be
concerned that that could happen
i don't know enough about the technology
and about the market to really yeah i
mean
social media and whatnot it seems like
it's a complicated uh system of
interactions between people and who the
users are and so forth and so on
um i do know that that uh new york
post's uh story about hunter biden's
laptop was real news
and could have affected the outcome of
the election and it was suppressed
and that uh twitter had a role in
suppressing it i do know
that the question of where the covet 19
virus originated and the role that a lab
leak
account could have played in the public
processing of that
event was real news
and that it was suppressed by people who
are trying to control
misinformation disinformation russian
disinformation campaigns and whatnot
so twitter has users i'm one of them and
it has a lot of users it's not as big as
facebook i gather it's not
but um it's important the ability to
construct
counter
platforms where people moving around and
whatnot
it's a kind of network dynamic that
maybe i should understand it better than
i do being a social scientist but i
don't think anyone understands it yeah
even people include inside twitter
which is fascinating it's a monster
because of just the bandwidth of
messaging and you don't know who is a
bot and who is a human that's a
fascinating dynamic and the whole and
the viral nature of negativity yeah
that all of those dynamics of course you
are probably the right person to
understand it from a
social scientist perspective from an
economics perspective but nobody really
understands and it's fascinating within
that domain
how do you
allow for free speech not allow for free
speech encourage free speech defend free
speech
and at the same time
manage
millions of ongoing conversations
from
just
becoming in insanely
uh chaotic
sort of from a from twitter perspective
they want people to be
happy to grow
to actually have difficult critical
conversations
and they you know the problem with
humans is they think they know what that
is and they
um think they can label things as
misinformation as as counterproductive
for healthy conversations in quotes
and
the problem is as we are learning humans
are not able to do that
effectively first of all power corrupts
there's something delicious about having
the power to label something as
misinformation you do that once
for something that might be obviously
misinformation and then you start
getting greedy you start getting excited
it feels good it feels good to label
something as
misinformation or disinformation that
you just don't like
and over time especially if there's a
culture inside of a company
that leans a certain political direction
or leans in all the groups that we
talked about leans a certain way
they'll start to
labels misinformation things they just
don't like and there's
that power is delicious and it corrupts
you have to construct mechanisms like
the founding fathers did for somehow
preventing you
from allowing that power to get too
delicious
at least that's my perspective on what's
going well i'll just tell you personally
uh i'm excited about the prospect i'm
glad to see musk making the move that
he's making and we'll see what happens
at twitter and so forth
you look you're looking forward for the
uh what did he say let's make twitter
more fun i'm looking forward to uh
to the fun
you